franck ou finira par un pass moi l'autre
qu on va rappeler personnes à nos
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoint voilà
on appelle une personne et on lui dit
pas ce mois l'autre con si la personne
passe une personne elle gagne un cadeau
d'accord un cadeau ce sera c'est toi
ball
moi je ferai des voyages ou pas offrir
des catalogues de voyages comme ça en
tant que la personne gagne quelque chose
on va appeler un restaurant s'appelle là
mais déjà maintenant oui à salon de
provence
adacore ipad pas demain d'accord moi
demain ça m'arrangeait me fait derrière
tout le monde se bat j'en ai tout appris
les rats quittent le navire
wii passe moi l'autre qu'on passe -
l'autre con vite vite vite je t'explique
après des mois c'est le remplacement
l'autre con je t'en supplie un pardon si
sa fille ça alors qu'il a c'est toujours
le fait que tout le monde travaille
c'est laurent passe - autres convives
s'il te plaît mais laurent qui le
rendent à 6 laurent baffie
oui oui enfin si à toulouse top autant
de cons oui merci pratiquement mais j'ai
comme ma femme
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pardon tonye tonye passe moi l'autre
conne comment s'appelle comment sa fille
émilie emilie allô bonjour ml c'est
laurent baffie oui bonjour alors je te
sentais jc avec cyril hanouna pourri tu
vois qui sait oui et bien d'accord
engageant qu'elles passeront à l'autre
con donc à ton mari a eu le bon réflexe
dont vous venez de gagner un cadeau
incroyable
oui mais les dégâts est ce que tu es
déjà parti en safari en afrique
voir des éléphants de près ouais mais je
la vois je me sens mal à prendre des
barreaux
trompe oui bah oui d'accord
non là bas tous les soirs nous dérange
visiblement pardon c'est cyril hanouna
bonsoir oui avant toi ça va bien ah oui
les câbles de son respect quand les gens
me bats toi
enfin c'est normal ça fait ça avec tout
le monde oui vous avez été au oui sur
carillon sûr à côté de ça c'est ça que
vous aimeriez un appartement confortable
sur paris on va réaliser votre rêve et
mini et midi cécile linda oui je suis
venu sur une amie je me dis je vais est
ce que tu fais tu dans la vie milice
avait des enfants
oui oui l'année de combien la troisième
jour de vous faites quoi dans la vie tu
responsable de magasin
d'accord ils ont déjà aller à disneyland
les petits c'est pas disneyland paris
ouais c'est pas mal ce faire je peux le
faire ça parce que le comptable et
milito qui m'a dit et vous aimez les
pattes
vous aimez les pâtes ont dit oui parce
que tout le monde attend la balance
oui oui super
[Applaudissements]
émilie fournel a paris je vous offre un
smartphone
ah ouais personnes vous êtes combien
alors ils sont en famille pas l'ensemble
est le parleurs je veux entendre la
réaction de joie de la personne
je suis ravi et mehdi on se retrouve
tous les samedis sur ces huit dans la
grande marque à ces vous avez fait la
première de l'émission
donc je voulais vous remercier à six est
reconduit vous aimez bien laurent baffie
est il écrit et les papilles les pattes
vous aimez les pâtes les très méchants
et millions ou nord-est
donc adieu ballon